qu'on fasse un jeu d'éveil pour se
remonter le moral et gallagher le
strakka croate je suis à de faire votre
connaissance à tous et à toutes vraiment
rien je regarde mal et je fais danic qui
sentent le cheval non non vous même je
peux me permettre theft auto menthol
clic
on est deuxièmes maintenant pas web on
regarde pas ce qu'on appelle c'est le
mensonge le vrai ennemi mais qu'est ce
que la l'appui du véhicule moi je peux
être là chef de l'animation sera la chef
de ton cul et tu vis tes poches au dodo
annick testud fait espèce de clochards
la soeur de l'un ont fait des
attouchements d'avira nan je t'ai pas
même pas la camair et coulos pauv'con ou
à la trêve tu prends tes affaires et tu
te casses on a fait tous crever à cause
de toi tu veux rester non donc tu prends
ton gros cul ton sac en jute t'offre
lambeaux tu viens ici tu te casses nous
convoque pas conduit tu veux qu'on votre
regard de la mêlée la kia motors 1 2 3 4
sa limite et c'est vrai
on voit revenir hanter fleuve et et
raisins secs et tu rentres à montélimar